Speaker 1: One of the other ways you can tell
that the 2024 election is really getting going
in earnest is the frequency with which attack
ads are being released.
We looked at a Ron DeSantis ad, we looked
at a Trump ad, we looked at a pack ad, all
sorts of different ads.
Lately, a failed former President Donald Trump
has now released such a ridiculously dangerous
ad that it's hard to believe anyone would
even fall for this.
But it's being released for a reason, and
it's because Trump knows his audience.
This ad that Trump put out yesterday, it's
about 90 seconds, 100 seconds long.
It invokes multiple conspiracy theories.
It attacks a trans woman.
It's really, really insane stuff.
Let's take a look at it.
Speaker 5: It's an invasion of America.
Streets flooded with poison, killing millions.
Enemies and tyrants on opposite sides of the
globe.
Laugh at us.
Wars threaten us.
The threat of nuclear annihilation, once forgotten,
is now real again.
America's weakness has become their strength.
The global elitist.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So you have to understand that the visual
components here are a big part of this.
The Great Reset just appeared on the screen.
That's that's the these what Deep State folks
love to talk about the Great Reset.
They love to demonize the World Economic Forum.
They had statistics on screen about fentanyl
seized at the border.
Now, of course, you might say to yourself,
well, if they're seizing the fentanyl, then
it's not getting into the country.
Right.
Like, isn't that a good sign that that our
Border patrol is doing a good job.
They don't care.
It's all conjecture, it's all propaganda,
it's all performative.
Speaker 5: Send your kids to war.
Who tell you a woman is a man and a man is
a woman.
Speaker 1: Okay?
And at this point they put trans woman Dylan
Mulvaney.
At least I think that's who this is up on
the screen.
They tell you a man is a woman and a woman
is a man.
This is completely ridiculous when it comes
to policy, as we've talked about before, they
are dramatically overplaying their hand nationally
on this issue.
But within the MAGA, Right.
Just being anti-trans for the hell of it is
playing really well.
These are big applause lines when they do
events in public.
Speaker 5: Teach your children their country,
their faith.
Their beliefs are a lie they have.
Every facet of American governance.
Weaponized it against you while they watch
our cities burn and violent crime skyrocket,
you and your families pay the price.
Speaker 1: Remember?
Long term crime is down.
Violent crime is down.
The murder rate is down long term.
There have been shorter term spikes, some
of which happened under Trump.
And as we will talk about on the program tomorrow.
The red states of the United States are dramatically
more violent than the blue states.
Speaker 5: Out of control inflation, an economy.
Speaker 1: Wrecked.
Now, remember, the unemployment rate is extraordinarily
low.
Job creation is high.
Inflation has been high.
It has now declined consecutively for many,
many months.
Under Joe Biden, every it's hard to go 5 seconds
without finding lies, which is sort of the
way it is under with a Trump speech as well.
Speaker 5: A nation in decline.
This is Joe Biden's America feeling weak,
but one man.
One movement can change all that for us.
Put America the middle class.
Unidentified: First and put the globalists
the elitist and the corrupt in their place.
Bring back the.
Speaker 5: Pride and the American dream to
let the world know.
Don't mess with us.
One man focused on the true owners of this
great land.
One movement focused on the true priorities
Make America great for us.
Again.
Speaker 1: Okay.
That's a Trump that you might think.
Is that a trailer to some dystopian movie?
Is that a satire?
Is that an SNL skit?
No.
That's actually a Trump ad, including three
times in the 100 seconds, the same video of
when Joe Biden tripped walking up to Air Force
One three times.
That's included up and then riddled with corrosive
and destructive lies.
I guess if there's any praise that we get,
if there's any silver lining here, it's the
ad doesn't include lies about who won in 2020.
Would that is that is that something that
we could find is a redeeming quality here?
If you knew someone who said this stuff to
you in person.
Right.
The arguments, if you can even call them that,
that this ad makes.
If you went to a dinner party and someone
rattled off what this ad says to you, you
might say, Do you need it?
Need a psych eval?
Is this someone who has become completely
delusional and is experiencing a paranoid
delusional event or state to the point that
they need to be evaluated because it is so
disconnected from reality?
But this is all they have.
They've abandoned policy.
Notice that there's no policy proposals there.
It's transpeople are bad and Biden's bad and
World War Three.
But there's no actual policy proposals there.
So this is all they have.
This is my expectation, maybe not so much
about what the primary will be like, because,
remember, Trump hasn't won the primary yet.
He probably will.
He hasn't won it yet, but he's already campaigning
against Joe Biden in the primary.
Maybe they'll have to pretend to talk about
policy, although maybe not.
But we can already see that it's going to
be a general election once again where whoever
is the Republican nominee will not utter a
word about policy, and it's because they have
lost on policy